>> (narrator)
An inguinal hernia
is the abnormal protrusion
of abdominal contents,
such as the
intestine,
through an area of weakness
in the groin muscles.
The protruding intestine
resides in what is known
as a "hernia sac."
In some cases, untreated
hernias cause complications.
For example, if part
of the intestines
becomes stuck in
the hernia opening,
its blood supply
may be cut off,
leading to the death
of intestinal tissue.
This is called a
"strangulated hernia."
If a surgeon feels
you are at risk
for this complication, he or
she will likely recommend
elective
hernia repair.
Traditional open
inguinal hernia repair
requires a relatively
large single incision.
Newer laparoscopic
techniques
require only tiny keyhole
incisions, or puncture wounds,
which generally result in
a shorter recovery period.
When you arrive
at the hospital,
an intravenous line
will be started
and you may be given a
sedative to help you relax.
Laparoscopic inguinal
hernia repairs
are done under
general anesthesia,
which will put you to sleep for
the duration of the operation.
A breathing tube will
be temporarily inserted
through your mouth
and into your throat
to help you breathe
during the operation.
A catheter may also be
placed in your bladder
to drain
your urine.
These will be removed at
the end of the procedure.
An uncomplicated laparoscopic
inguinal hernia repair
usually takes between
30 and 60 minutes.
Depending on your situation
and your surgeon's experience,
he or she will choose
one of two types
of laparoscopic
approaches--
extraperitoneal
laparoscopic repair
or trans-abdominal
preperitoneal repair.
To gain access
to the hernia,
your surgeon will use sharp
instruments called "trocars"
to create three small
holes or ports
through your
abdominal wall.
The location of these
ports will vary,
depending on your
surgeon's preference
and the type
of procedure.
One of these ports
is usually located
at your navel
or umbilicus.
Carbon dioxide gas
will then be pumped
through the umbilical port
to puff up your abdomen,
so its contents can be
viewed more easily.
Next, your surgeon will
insert the laparoscope
through the
umbilical port.
Images from its camera are
projected onto a video monitor
in the
operating room.
Your surgeon will then
pass various instruments
through the
other ports.
These will be used to
dissect away the hernia sac
and to tack a piece of mesh
over the hernia opening.
This will prevent
the intestine
from slipping back
through the opening.
Before removing
the laparoscope,
your surgeon will take
one final look around
for areas of bleeding
or other damage.
A port valve is
briefly left in place
to allow all the carbon dioxide
to escape from the abdomen.
Finally, the
keyhole incisions
are closed with
sutures or staples,
and covered
with bandages.
After the surgery, your
breathing tube and catheter
will be removed,
and you will be taken to the
recovery area for monitoring.
You'll be given pain
medication, as needed.
When you're able
to drink liquids,
your intravenous line
will be removed.
Most patients can
leave the hospital
three to five hours
after the procedure.
(music)